for olga renberg this is a moment of
gut-wrenching relief her mother ludmila
is now safe in edmonton after escaping
the violence of kiev it's a huge relief
so now i have one person less to worry
about but for olga there is guilt as
well and a longing to help her homeland
let him do what i can
honestly i'm praying every second
that they will survive calgary's elena
burden is in poland she met her sister
at the border with ukraine for just a
moment this week long enough for a hug
and a promise that she would take her
eight and ten-year-old niece and nephew
back to canada where they would be safe
my sister tanya
so she said i can give you my kids hand
to hand because i trust you you can take
care about them
but
i will go back to ukraine an impossible
decision facing so many mothers in the
country right now to leave with their
kids or bring them to safety before
returning to fight women are involved in
every conceivable aspect of this from
from the front lines to to being the
refugees themselves to caring for the
refugees
thirty-two-year-old alana bashinska has
become a soldier as well
in her old life she taught people how to
use makeup now she is defending her city
it's my country it's my cities my here
are my families and my friends
my
animals so why should i wait until
someone will rescue me so alana fights
as elena opens her home and oga
advocates and prays
just three stories in a country with
millions more
heather urex west global news calgary